[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
communiquer est un acte naturel
déjà il ya quelques semaines lorsque
vous avez fait la démarche d'acheter les
billets pour venir assister à notre
conférence vous avez exprimé le besoin
de communiquer avec nous et de manière
plus simple lever la main ceux qui ont
parlé à quelqu'un aujourd'hui à son
chien son chat ça marche aussi à
christophe et directrice de recherche au
cnrs depuis de nombreuses années elle
étudie le développement des capacités
cognitives chez les nouveau-nés et
confirme que l'enfant dès sa naissance
fait élever communiqué nous sommes donc
tous d'accord pour dire scientifiques et
non scientifique que le besoin et la
capacité de communiquer chez l'être
humain activée pourquoi quelques années
plus tard ce qui est spontanée naturelle
à la naissance devient compliqué et
empreint de conflits lorsque nous
grandissons laissez moi vous raconter
histoires
j'ai passé une partie de mon enfance en
afrique j'ai grandi avec mes frères en
doré de mes parents mes parents et mes
et elle l'afrique profondément
viscéralement et voulait nous donner une
enfance hors norme une expérience de vie
exceptionnel et je pense qu'à ce niveau
là ils vont très bien rempli leur
contrat
en effet nos activités du week-end
consistait à les voir les hippopotames
se baigner dans la rivière se promener
dans la beauce
j'avais pour animal de campagne et une
biche cochon est mon voisin à charge
mais la plus belle leçon l'afrique
mannone est une leçon de vie
exceptionnelle qui a milieu de tout cela
nous sommes dans les années 80 nous
vivons au fin fond de la brousse mon
père fait pousser de la canne à sucre
pour cela ils emploient de nombreuses
personnes dans ce qu'on appelle les
coupeurs de gamme
ils viennent le temps de la récolte
grossir les rangs de l'équipe
mon père est souvent préoccupés par la
situation précaire de ces familles il ne
comprend pas pourquoi lui des enfants en
pleine santé alors que d'autres meurent
dans l'est
village d'à côté un jour médecins sans
frontières entre en contact avec mon
père et lui dit on va être de passage
dans la région
mon père très excité les invite à venir
passer une journée à l'usiné
je vous rappelle que nous vivons à 200
km du plus proche hôpital pouvoir offrir
des soins de santé gratuitement à son
équipe était inespéré il prépare tout
prévient tout le monde leur dit vous
pourrez venir avec nos femmes et nos
enfants tout le monde belle soignée
vacciner gratuitement le jour j arrive
mon père est fébrile les médecins sont
là et pourtant personne ne se présente
personne ne vient rencontrer les
médecins
la journée passe médecin contentèrent de
repartir et mon père s'empresse d'aller
rencontrer ses équipes je ne comprends
pas que s'est il passé
pourquoi personne n'est venu hélas un
gars dit à mon père tue ses patrons dans
la vie je vais revoir peut-être huit ou
dix enfants
sur ces huit ou dix enfants un ou deux
vont mourir c'est comme ça c'est la vie
c'est dieu qui décide si tu fais venir
les médecins ils vont tous les vacciner
je sais pas si j'ai les moyens de
doucier nourrir mon père comme vous
sûrement aujourd'hui étaient sous le
choc
cette histoire est horrible et pourtant
pas tant si l'on accepte que tout est
une question de point de vue
le problème que je venais d'avoir mon
père c'est de penser que sa situation
était celle des autres c'était de penser
qu'il avait identifié le bon problème et
que donc il avait la bonne solution
ce que j'ai appris ce jour là c'est que
nous voulons toujours imposer nos points
de vue nos modes de fonctionnement
nous sommes toujours persuadés d'avoir
la bonne réponse de savoir et la plupart
du temps nous nous trompons par exemple
au travail
combien de fois nous rencontrant des
problèmes de communication cela fait 20
ans que je suis directrice dans le
commerce de détail
mon rôle consiste à commercialiser des
items correctement pour que vous
consommateurs
ayez le goût de les acheter il ya
quelques années de ça je me souviens
j'avais une mission réaliser un mur de
google un nom très très grosse mission
je vous rassure je rassure quand même
les novices cela ne prends pas ma came
marchandising pour faire un mur de
boboul j'ai donc entier salomé directeur
et son équipe pensent ans l'âge tâche
vraiment simple je m'en suis occupé
seulement voilà au bout de quelques
jours le projet n'avance et pas
d'indicés pas le résultat n'était pas là
je suis donc retourné par mon directeur
et je lui ai posé la question
as tu été clairs sur ce que tu voulais
wim at il dit as tu vraiment expliqué
évidemment et tu retourner voir la
personne pourrait expliquer et demander
pourquoi ça n'avançait pas oui m'at-il
dit oui j'ai fait tout ça comment lui à
thuré expliqué de la même façon que la
première fois tout était dit mon
directeur avait pris pour acquis que la
personne à qui il avait confié la tâche
aurait le même point de vue que lui sur
la situation
la même perception de la tâche à
accomplir le problème étant que l'été ne
dure que six semaines au québec recevait
déjà des soupes d'hiver et mais nous
nous ne se vendait toujours pas le
problème que venais d'avoir mon
directeur c'est de penser savoir à la
place de l'autre personne
il avait juste oublié que l'étape
indispensable d'une bonne communication
lorsque nous voulons transmettre une
information c'est d'accepter que l'autre
puisse avoir un point de vue différent
sur la situation et surtout que cette
différence puissent l'empêcher
d'accomplir sa tâche correctement alors
je pense que vous vous dites non ceux
des pièges je tombe pas date dans à
l'entrée on vous a distribué une feuille
de papier oui vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
je vais vous demander de prendre cette
feuille de papier s'il vous plaît
nous allons réaliser un petit exercice
qui est très simple je vais vous
demander d'écouter les consignes vous
allez d'abord fermer les yeux de
réaliser les tâches que je vais vous
donner et surtout ne pas parler ni poser
de questions allons-y
je vais vous demander de plier la
feuille en deux
tourner la feuille vers la droite
repliée la feuille en deux déchiré le
point en haut à droite
tourner la feuille vers la gauche
déchiré le coin en haut à gauche
repliez la feuille une dernière fois en
deux et enfin déchiré le coin en bas à
droite et dur sur un trépied la fire je
vais vous demander d'ouvrir les yeux de
déplier vos feuilles et s'il vous plaît
de les monter au dessus de vos têtes
afin que tout le monde puisse les voir
de très belles créativité par la
magnifique
j'ai quelques questions pour vous
trouvez vous que l'exercice était
compliqué est ce que le vocabulaire
était trop élaboré est-ce que la tâche
demandée une qualification particulière
non alors pourquoi tant de différence
parce que tout est une question de
perception
cet exercice est la preuve que nous
avons tous un point de vue différents
sur une même situation et accepter cette
différence c'est déjà un pas vers une
meilleure communication
je voulais vous raconter une dernière
anecdote qui est arrivé à mon grand père
nous sommes dans les années 40
mes grands parents vivent en afrique
déjà à cette époque la famine et la
sécheresse font rage un jour mon
grand-père est convoquée pour être jurée
dans un procès d'un brossé pour
cannibalisme oui cannibalisme le vieil
homme qui est jugé ce jour là doit
expliquer pourquoi il a mangé son enfant
voilà ce qu'il a déclaré nous n'avions
plus rien à manger
mon fils était mort et j'ai décidé de le
manger pour pouvoir survivre pour
pouvoir essayer de sauver le rêve de ma
famille le reste de mon village
si je ne l'avais pas fait nous serions
tous morts quelque part par sa mort il
nous a aidés il a aidé sa famille
cette histoire est horrible
injustifiable inqualifiable et encore
aujourd'hui je me demande comment mon
grand père c'est d'être d'une beauté
incroyable
a pu juger de façon légale une situation
empreint d'une grande injustice
cet exemple ces textes
cette expérience est vraiment la preuve
d'une communication sans issue sans fin
impossible irréversible si mon grand
père n'a pas eu ce choix nous nous avons
des millions possibilité de changer de
façon de communiquer tous les jours en
acceptant le point de vue de l'autre ce
que l'afrique m'a appris ce jour là
c'est que nous voulons toujours imposer
nos points de vue nos expériences nos
modes de fonctionnement gâche ainsi
l'état indispensable d'une bonne
communication
l'acceptation de la différence de
perception de l'autre accepter cette
différence c'est accepter qu'un problème
puisse avoir plusieurs solutions
une histoire plusieurs fins c'est
accepter que les changes ne se passera
pas forcément comme nous l'avons prévu
c'est accepter que nous pouvons nous
tromper
peut-être devrions-nous réapprendre à
communiquer telli que nous apprend à
partager les idées et si nous apprenons
d'abord à les respecter
merci
[Applaudissements]